[Musique]
il est
improbable
[Musique]
prix
les itinérants durci d'helsinki se
retrouvent ici tous les matins pour
réserver leur lit du soir
ils ne sont plus très nombreux
[Musique]
les autorités ont pris les grands moyens
pour les sortir de la rue en payant le
programme un toit d'abord
miguel roja se ne vais plus dans la rue
depuis plusieurs années il habite dans
un complexe de 35 appartements pour sans
abri
le havre presse
yu na loba risque natech
de cette
seule condition pour y être admis
s'engager par écrit à essayer d'aller
mieux novare et c'est un teigneux you
can't rinckenbach cette chicane smoke
battre des adagios want to get better is
enough
les sur l'ouest
bns en prime ce texte
offrir l'accès aux quais l'estomac ou
last.fm
recover begins et batman
il y a près de 5000 personnes comme
eagle en finlande qui bénéficient du
programme un toit d'abord dans des
immeubles construits ou rénovés pour
leur donner une nouvelle chance uh tous
respectent do you may use de basic
rights watch everybody dance
now
is
a good thing saut petter fredriksson
était jusqu'à tout récemment le grand
responsable du programme qui a démarré
en 2008
douze ans plus tard le nombre de sans
abri a diminué des deux tiers
pour y arriver l'état fait lors des des
bourses 30 millions d'euros soit 45
millions de dollars par année
trois années
et des reason fils titre au
coaching for one peut y aller
ce programme permet de réaliser des
économies annuelles en services sociaux
et soins de santé dont le montant est
supérieur au coût du programme un
investissement plus que rod à mme irene
a rompu
avec son petit salaire et des
prestations dette sociale miel arrive à
payer une partie de surloyer c'est une
condition qui est requise par le
programme
le reste est couvert par d'état
et christ les candidats sont recrutés
dans des centres de jour comme celui-ci
seul problème le programme est victime
de sa popularité est supérie
la finlande comme le canada a fermé
plusieurs hôpitaux psychiatriques au
cours des dernières années résultat on
observe une hausse marquée de la
population itinérante qui souffre de
troubles mentaux
oui c'est
comme
indy lights in baby you not able to keep
le principal promoteur du programme
reconnaît que le système a ses limites
ce n'est pas accompagnée des services
adéquats de ce
système
dans son ancienne vie milliards d'euros
à 7 et chanteurs et musiciens sa
dépendance à diverses substances l'a
entraînée dans une profonde dépression
mais aujourd'hui ils se considèrent à
peu près guéri blake de nature de
sécurité dans la graphie durable des ice
souci de bury ayem et michel michaut
painting l'expérience finlandaise
démontre que c'est précisément l'accès à
un logement qui amènent des itinérants à
chercher de l'aide et à obtenir les
soins pour s'en sortir